i remember
2006 before i started my job at my
financial sales at welcome funds
i was
so excited to get this job in this
mortgage industry
right and my buddy was there who's
making 250 grand a year he's like sas
you're the man i'm gonna recruit you
they're gonna love you you're a great
salesperson great personality he's
hyping me up tell me why i should work
at this job they're gonna pay you five
grand a month to train for six months
you're gonna you know make five grand a
month boom they're gonna they're gonna
fly out to california you're gonna train
in san francisco all this all this all
this like this sounds sick he's making
crazy money this is 2006 keep in mind
the financial recession the great
recession was in 2008 as we all know
and i was so
stoked for this job i went they flew me
out to chicago they picked me up in a
limo
they i flew i killed the interview i got
hired it was amazing i went through all
the checklist boom boom boom boom boom
the last test
was to do a background check with hr
and
flying colors all good no worries i'm
supposed to start like the following
week i get a call from hr and they say
sorry we did the background check
but we regret to and that's always how
it starts we regret to inform you
that we cannot hire you because
your driver's license was suspended
for failure to pay a citation something
something like i'm like
okay yeah it was a traffic thing i had i
i was fighting it in court it was a
ticket
it was like a stupid it was a traffic
infraction
i was like what does this have to do
with selling mortgages yeah and they go
well you know technically you have to
drive to the office or you're going to
be in a car
and you've
been some [ __ ] excuse and i didn't
get the job talk about wanting to
uh
slingshot someone into the sun let me
choose my my choice of words there yeah
i would have done something very very
bad to hr
what happens i don't get the job i'm
super depressed i'm just disgusted i'm
so sad i'm upset
all right you know two weeks later i
gotta get back on the ground it took me
a full-on week or two to like get over
this was gonna be my dream job making
money sales my guys killing doesn't work
my buddy what happens i get this job
still job i've been in 15 years yeah
life insurance life settlements i get
the job and
lo and behold one year later the
mortgage crisis happens the company goes
bankrupt defunct it was a company called
fremont investment loan i wanted this
job so damn badly a year later my
buddies asking me for a job the guy that
was hooking me up with the job yeah the
entire mortgage industry got screwed so
this brings me back to my initial point
you can't always get what you want but
if you try sometime so great job yeah
thank you but the point is this
there's i i
not to get all religious i believe the
universe there's things going on in the
universe that are beyond our control
okay
and you might think you really really
really want that job or you might really
really really want it to your
relationship to work out with a certain
person right or you really really want
this thing but it doesn't happen there's
a reason the unit there's a reason for
it there's a reason for it in my opinion
so the the the irony of me begging you
know this job to happen me
um trying to manifest this job and then
a year plus later my buddies calling me
up saying hey can you get me a job at
your firm
i mean that's that's that's kind of the
universe saying yeah exactly it's pretty
wild so anyway here's the point here
the lesson is this we talked about
quitting your job will it make it hap
would it make you happier people tend to
adapt back to who they are you can't run
away from yourself we talked about pbd
story you're always placing blame on
others not looking in the mirror you
can't always get what you want
maybe quitting
gives you a better feeling in the short
term but what you really need to
consider are the long-term effects of
what you're doing because you can't run
away from
yourself talk is money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke